in this country one of Jeffrey Epstein's
accusers is providing chilling new
insight into his alleged sex trafficking
operation Maria farmer says Epstein
sexually assaulted her more than 20
years ago she filed a lawsuit against
the Epstein estate just six days ago in
her first TV interview farmer alleged
that Epstein had extensive surveillance
inside his home including tiny pinhole
cameras he showed you cameras throughout
the house mm-hmm
the main thing he did when I walked in I
thought was interesting he showed me
where the camera would the men
monitoring everything were so when you
if you're facing the house there's a
window on the right it's barred that's
the that's the room the media room is
what he called it and so there was a
door that looked like an invisible door
with all this limestone and everything
and you push it and you go in and I saw
all the cameras what it was was like old
televisions basically it's like stacked
you know they were monitors inside this
cabinet and there were men sitting here
and I looked on the cameras and I saw
toilet toilet bed bed toilet bed I'm I
am never gonna use the restroom here and
I'm never gonna sleep here you know I
mean it was very obvious that they were
like monitoring private moments she
believes there are tapes the question is
who has them tomorrow we'll have much
more of my interview with Maria farmer
including how she is continuing the
fight for justice
even after Epstein's death in jail
that's right here on CBS this morning